i just think people got to see wikipedia
i would love to do that but every lawyer
has said not possible so we talked about
that a little bit yeah we talked about a
little bit before the show because i
said this to james o'keefe as well
i said sue wikipedia the organization
directly and the issue everyone says is
oh but it's user-generated content no
it's not well then why does every lawyer
tell me that it's there because they
haven't gone to the website
if there's a lawyer watching this that
can sue wikipedia with me send me an
email so you guys are saying before the
show you're saying on wikipedia you go
with the article sorry yeah and then
there's a byline and the byline says
from wikipedia so they're basically
claiming they are the author of this
story and uh yeah so uh we have this
story from wikipedia
lauren is it is shari shari shari is a
canadian alt-right political activist
and white white nationalist and youtuber
lauren are you all right i'm not
alt-right and i'm not a white
nationalist but
they and you know in an article with a
living person you have to at least after
this put someone's rejection of a label
and they just won't even do that and
that's in their own
like terms of you know how how the
website should function
they just don't care well so here's the
issue right um you can see they've got
weird the interesting the sources here
for alt-right and there it's an a and a
b
oh and you're not supposed to use
opinion pieces for like hardcore claims
that could hurt someone's reputation but
they do it anyway here's the funny thing
on my wikipedia they don't
they've actually rejected a bunch of
op-eds that were too over the top bro i
don't know how you got away with that
because he knows wikipedia can be sued
lauren because i keeps well so so with
the articles about me there was one um
this is really interesting it said tim
poole has donated to multiple
republicans and then someone in the talk
section said if you look at if you
actually search federal records tim
poole has donated to more democrats than
republicans
sure you can say he's donated to because
it's like i think it's like rand paul
but it's about what's left out of the
story that matters exactly and so but
then the editors were like i don't think
this is an accurate piece if they're
omitting something like this and so they
rejected it outright yeah i always look
at this and they could you know i would
consider myself a documentary filmmaker
you wouldn't even know i made
documentaries if you read my wikipedia
page and that's the what i've gotten the
most views for is my films that i've
made and you wouldn't even know reading
this well so so here's the point we're
bringing up with lawsuits
this is what i said to james o'keefe it
says on
wikipedia.com.org sorry lauren southern
from wikipedia the free encyclopedia so
you know there's there's some serious
questions that need to be answered by
many different courts from many
different countries it may be that i'm
wrong and the court decides that if a
new if a media outlet includes a byline
of their own corporate name
but
commenters provided the information for
the formation of that article you can't
sue them i would love a judge to pass
that precedent and then just watch the
absolute psychotic chaos that would
unfold on the internet so right now
that's what you need to understand about
wikipedia first i'll present to you like
this
if um
sheamus over here freedom tunes
yeah over here posts on twitter
that lauren southern is you know a big
stupid dude
lauren southern did a backflip a
statement of fact and that causes you
damages because you have a vow of no
backflips uh well you can't sue twitter
because the post says at jameis coughlin
yeah but what if it said at twitter on
it
you could sue twitter right
i mean of course of course the premise
makes sense but i've never seen anyone
do it what i have seen people do is so
it's the whole what's a publisher what's
a platform what is it section 230 that
covers this in the states yeah um and
people
in australia they've sued
uh google because google they choose
what articles you see they are
they're a publisher they publish things
and they use wikipedia as their main
source it literally comes up in a
separate sidebar like if you look up on
google or in southern they feature that
and publish that so you can sue google
for this because that's what they
publish and it's been successful in the
courts before really yeah well here's
what i'm saying the so when we had james
here i mentioned this and he was like
yeah but you know section 230 and i'm
like yo the byline on this wikipedia
article is wikipedia no one else so
imagine this imagine at timcast.com i
tell people hey if you comment we'll
take all your comments and then post it
as a legitimate news article could you
imagine if it said you know timcast.com
article byline tim poole and then it
said you know a political high-profile
political individual took action you
know i did something that was clearly
false like you know uh nancy pelosi
punches baby in face
and then like
clearly defamatory clearly uh libelous
clearly slander
but well you can't sue me but does the
language matter here because it says
from
wikipedia not by wikipedia and then
it'll tell you these specific editors
who i would love a judge to answer that
question yeah because if a judge says
well you know
that doesn't really count then i'll be
like
then i would love a judge to explain
how you can have an article it says
article on the article with a headline
lauren southern with a byline below it
and now the organization that published
it is exempt
whoa i'm reading something on here it
says i was demonetized by youtube and
banned from paypal i've never been
banned from paypal i use paypal every
day
and i'm not demonetized on youtube so
this is that's a false statement that's
not even true what are they referring to
you know it when i was living in
australia my wikipedia said i was
permanently banned from australia they
can literally just make [ __ ] up it's
wild but so so so the issue is it needs
to be tested in the courts and we need
this i don't know if it would go to the
supreme court or where it would end but
a judge needs to answer for how this
applies section 230 because wikipedia
does a lot here's another thing you see
that lock symbol next to your name yeah
that means it is not open to the public
interesting the lock means only specific
wikipedia individuals i have no idea how
to access that right i would have no
idea how to edit your page as a member
of the public okay so here's another
this is a whole on conspiracy world that
i'm gonna get into there's an editor on
my page uh it seems like gray something
and he
all day every day is sitting there
editing like michael malus's page jack
posovic's page cernovich all of these
big right-wing figures i swear he's
being
paid by some sort of organization to do
this
like i genuinely believe there are
people being paid to edit wikipedia
articles
i would be shocked if there weren't no
no no no i i i know them you do okay so
i'm not crazy because i was like this
guy how is he sitting all day on
wikipedia just fighting in the comments
section
they're called reputation management
firms yes yeah i try to change hillary
clinton's wikipedia after the emails
dropped and talked about sydney
blumenthal and osprey global solutions
and within like 30 seconds it was
removed within like six and they're just
sitting there monitoring it because
they're getting paid to do this and
you're right they've done reputation
firms well they'll create fake articles
and put the asterisk off them on i
actually actually know people who do
this um i've actually
had uh events put on so i did an event a
while back with a buddy of mine and one
of the sponsors of the event was a
reputation management firm they they
they uh
here's what how it was explained to me
they were like
you ever have the media lie about you
okay well here's what we'll do
we will get placement in several medium
tier blogs
of stories and then we know how to work
seo to make sure they appear on the top
of google and then make them more
prominent then we'll go in and we'll
we'll have our employees argue on
wikipedia against the inclusion of
defamatory content yes now of course
these guys didn't say to me like we're
gonna lie and cheat and smear people to
ruin their lives they said the opposite
they were like the media writes fake
stories we protect you from that that
was that's that's how they frame it now
it may be the people i know actually are
you know doing the right thing but there
are people who do the wrong thing yeah
what that's what i was gonna say is
what's scary is that obviously can be
used in the reverse the media are
writing accurate articles about you and
you're having
the wealthy can pay i i did a video on
this called sainthood for sale you can
literally pay for your reputation and if
you can't afford your reputation if
you're if you're a 19 year old kid or
even a high schooler that just gets
slandered in a local paper as a racist
and you don't have anything else online
about you and that's the first thing
that comes up your job options are
limited in the future you're screwed
over and you're not gonna have a money
for a lawyer you're not even gonna know
the first thing what to do
whereas if you're extremely wealthy i
actually buy sainthood i i think
actually there's something interesting
here with the uh your wikipedia
there's a question over
i think the question of whether you can
sue them has to do with whether or not
they're making opinion statements
that you know um but i think if
wikipedia actually says something
happened to you that isn't true i think
it's clear-cut lawsuit for wikipedia so
they have the biography don't you have
to prove malice in america um
yes you have to prove
that so actual malice is not like hatred
it means
that either
they knew it was false
or they were reckless as to the
publication of the information reckless
i'd say that yeah well so there's an
interesting thing here that wikipedia
might win the suit on the on the
question of malice and be like we didn't
know this person was doing this we'll
ban them instantly you know and then
that's all that can ever really be done
i don't know for sure i think it needs
to be i also really want to clarify the
public because people say this all the
time they're like oh well if it's untrue
just sue them any lawyer you go to about
defamation they'll initially say to you
all right hundred thousand dollar down
payment and there's like a five percent
chance we'll win like that's right and
then you have to pay
all throughout the years for that like
do you think people oh just sue them no
the media can get away with so much this
is fake
real quick though lauren i'm pretty sure
if you if you started a give send go
to uh i was going to bring it to just
hire you know lawyers and and do these
suits i'm pretty sure you'd make this is
what terrifies me and you should do that
we'll go into this in a second but
that's why justin trudeau calling up the
emergency acts and slamming down on the
crowdfunding is like
that was i was always like well at least
you can crowdfund it well if we want to
buy public property and turn into a
private property in terms of a public
park at least we can crowdfund it which
is why
money doesn't always buy you influence
but if you have influence you can often
get money so i i don't i don't know your
financial background i don't think
you're you're a millionaire or a
billionaire lawyer i don't i don't know
i totally yeah
here's my point though people people
people know you well enough they they
they like you enough that if you said
this is defamatory slanderous not only
is it to um i mean
damages might be a challenge in a
lawsuit what damages have you incurred
due to them calling you white
nationalists there could maybe be an
argument for um you know familial
emotional i don't know i'm not a lawyer
so that could be tough
but my point is if you said hey i'm
going to see wikipedia and i need help
people will help you and you know
that's influence yeah it's from i've
spoken to lawyers and you know even pro
bono lawyers that i've spoken to they're
just like it's so hard like very very
few people are successful the only
successes like i said have been on
google i haven't found a single
successful wikipedia lawsuit yeah you
got it maybe there's like one but he
like bankrolled the absolute crap gotta
try i would imagine that's hard like not
only does it mean expensive but it takes
a long time oh yeah they just want to
make your life yeah you're 20 they will
torment you to make sure you don't set a
precedent
torment just keep you in the legal
system for a decade if they can and
i've never seen it be partly because i
don't like involving the legal system
unless it's absolutely last
you know the last year
ready yeah we're going to wide shot
ladies and gentlemen are you prepared
for this
we're just getting ready for now okay
because we're going to see what's going
to happen so
thank you i don't remember what was i
talking about what's the wide shot i
have no idea something's happening
something something specific
i'm sure everybody already knows in the
audience oh no so we i don't don't i
don't know we're getting the camera i'm
not running on the joke rolling it's not
a joke oh god i'm scared
but uh so it's confirmed should we talk
about it then yeah we can talk about it
but that you were told they're coming up
i was told we were swatted again yeah
again are you serious
no it's gonna pull the white camera up
anybody who wants to walk in here is
gonna be on on they're gonna be on live
yeah do you think they would be
interested well i guess that's when he
comes in no he's busy he's on duty so
maybe not right serious you could spot
it again yeah third time third time's a
charm i guess they know that that's been
happening so they're they're ready for
it now but i don't understand why
they're coming up and coming in they do
a basic check now because they know us
and it was like it was big news in there
you can't get it
no give me the why so they're gonna
actually come in here i didn't i i
watched this on twitter i can't believe
that they're gonna come into this room
yeah it's correct yeah so they'll be
visiting us again just to make sure no
one's getting choked you know they're
doing their job
maybe you should
so i will say this
i used to have a mall sword behind me
it's a mall sword i went to a game store
and it's like some anime sword i don't
know what it is and i thought it was
like it was like 20 bucks i bought it
and then everyone's like what a dumb
anime sword like what a dumb mall sword
and so i actually ordered a wakazashi it
is people are like you've got it upside
down you're doing it wrong it's it's
it's dull it's not it's it's an or it's
ornamental it's beautiful calm down no
matter what i do people are like your
swords are bad welcome to the internet i
love that um
are they coming up what's that that's
what i want to see what happens
anticipation might happen during the
super chats well i guess we're just
we're just chilling and it's a wild
night man 2020 is crazy you know this is
uh so the first time we got swatted it
was right after marjory taylor green
and that was the
that was probably the worst one because
it was it was the first so the cops like
we had ton of cops he was crazy
and uh they came up the door opened
there was a cop there and he's like
fanning for me to come like we like like
we're live in the middle of a show like
i'm not getting up and these cops are
peeking in i didn't and he the cop walks
in looks around and i'm like what is
going on luke was here and he just keeps
talking like then he watches the cop
leave so then once i figured out what
had happened and i got the message
saying like we were swatted i was like
okay then i got up and ran out and said
what happened they told us
that was um that was the day after
marjorie taylor was here she was here on
january 5th yeah and so what i think
happened was
the show goes live at 8 p.m on january
5th
it wraps up on youtube at 10 pm on
january 5th that means most people won't
get the notification for it until
january 6 of all days to have marjorie
taylor green
so then
somebody swats us
the next time it happened i think it was
the day after we had andy no yeah and
james james
did you ever find who was doing it
uh
potential harm's way you're putting
people in potential animals in harm's
way people can get killed it's not a oh
dude i literally just had like a nervous
like yeah but my gun's on fire i'm like
what if a cop walked in and i was
literally holding that sword yeah i'm i
was actually like
gonna process that i feel that way
this person is a terrorist whoever made
that phone call as a terrorist is a
domestic terrorist and they might not be
american but they're a terrorist i
didn't i didn't you know so i didn't
want to bring it up that it happened you
know so like lydia's like messaging me
and now i'm just like i'm just gonna i
was wondering what you two were on about
yeah i was like
like texas guys
then when we heard that they were coming
up i'm like okay we'll do it better you
have to say something now we're gonna
say otherwise you know it's gonna
abruptly happen so i'm i'm trying to
verify exactly what's going on i'm
messaging people yeah i'm curious what
happens i guess we'll just have to wait
i think the second time they came by
they didn't come up here yeah talk to
people downstairs and then left yeah
they did like a suite but they weren't
on the show they know what this is and
here i'll tell you what really bothered
me about the first time it happened was
um
when they came here they said it was
accident circumstances they have a right
to enter the property
but uh they also said on the radio we
think this is a it's a swatting because
it's a political podcast which means
they outright lost exigent circumstances
right away by thinking that they have to
they have to believe that there is
something happening to they can violate
our fourth amendment rights
i'm not a fan of that like i can respect
them coming in rushing into danger and
all that stuff and being like but if
they genuinely think it's a swatting
like why are you here dude yeah yeah
but i'll say this i guess it's good that
they keep coming yeah well can't they
just like check the stream and be like
oh okay look who they have they probably
do probably but there's so many
employees in the house that it's yeah i
have no idea but that's why i'm like i
can't believe they're actually going to
come up
right i'm glad they do i'd rather they
check on us
i suppose give them a little high five
hey this is all like a hostage situation
and we all just have to act we've got
signs telling us to act normal no cop
i'm joking although that's what the sign
says
it's like everyone can see that's not
true the most um on on good terms you
can be with a cop is in a moment when
you're being swatted like they're so
much on your side at that point because
they think something bad is happening to
you yeah it's important to keep in mind
if something like that happens
oh
we think this is a first so yeah me too
as well disappointing what did you guys
think about that well it was uh it was
interesting it's not over yet i want to
make light of it but it's such a good
role i agree it's a horrible thing to do
just a dangerous
devilish terrible thing to do to a human
is this using i agree but we're at war
you know or maybe we're not we haven't
been a war since world war ii but the
world is in some sort of psychological
conflict so i understand why i'm just
telling you that it is very bad very
dangerous and don't do it again
well
thanks for coming lauren
yeah thanks for almost getting me killed
guys
i'm not in on the joke oh lauren's
holding the sword
nice plate that wasn't a joke maybe
maybe that's why you know we'll uh we'll
have a we'll get a little red light it
says like swatting on it
yeah good idea to be honest if you walk
through the other everyone put the
weapons down if you walk down the start
he'd probably be like nice sword and
look around and make sure no one's
getting hurt and then walk out
so i i don't think they're coming in
okay okay i think they're being told not
to and they're like okay okay so they're
actually listening and come say hi hang
on have everybody shout out dude they
want to be on the show so he can be like
confirmed yeah man
that'd be fun
so you know we'll get to super chats
smash the like button if you like the
show we'll do super chats in a second
so they're they're meeting with them
outside yeah they're andy's talking to
him same people same guys probably
all right well there we go
putin did it someone said in chat putin
did it putin did it
i think it wasn't true like putin is
sitting watching the show and he's like
betty i just can't take it anymore i
gotta get these guys yeah all right so i
i think we're good i think we're good
that's why i was like i didn't want to
say anything because if they don't come
up i'm like we're just not gonna bring
it up if it happens but i was told they
would be coming up i guess maybe they
were dissuaded
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you